Named for cartoonist Allison Bechdel,
the Bechdel Test is a tongue-in-cheek
benchmark for basic female content in movies.
A film passes the Bechdel Test when it has
At least 2 female characters
with names
who to talk to each other
About something
other than a man.
"Whatever with your however."
Sounds simple, but the vast majority of Hollywood films fail this simple test.
And some pass with just two lines.
"I need you to initial each box."
Here are some surprising films that pass the Bechdel Test.
"Tiffany, listen to me a sec.
I've got a really bad feeling about this.
I don't want you to go.
Now promise me you wont."
"Oh."
"Oh, Kitana."
"I have prayed...
for the day
when our love will bring us together again."
"Gloria, um, I wanted to congratulate you on getting the lead role in 'Sunset Dreams.'"
"Thanks."
I heard that you got a supporting role.
In general, horror movies have an easier time passing, due to lack of romance.
But, some action movies pass as well.
"Ginny, it's 5:40pm. Go join the party
have some champagne. You're making me feel like Ebenezer Scrooge."
"Thanks a lot, Ms. Gennaro."
"I had to watch out for my own neck!"
"Your neck.
Your precious, scrawny...
little NECK!"
"So you got any requests for your final flight?"
"Well, just what any flight attendant wants...
low maintenance passengers."
So, while the Bechdel Test is not exactly a measure of quality,
or even feminist content.
It is a simple way to highlight gender inequality in Hollywood.
And things are getting better.
In Sweden, theaters have started to include the Bechdel Test in their ratings.
And in 2013, films that pass the Bechdel Test made more money than films that fail.
But are box office receipts really about a metric?
Is there a better way to measure gender equality in entertainment?
What do you think?